hey 42 here every country is famous for
creating a certain culinary concoction
whatever you eat you can guarantee
there's a story behind it and the
certain country attached to its creation
but you shouldn't always rely on these
commonly told countries of origin
because some foods don't actually come
from where you fought here are nine
extremely common foods with unexpected
and surprising countries of origin so
you've just had an enjoyable meal at a
Chinese restaurant what would be the
perfect thing to end your meal a scoop
of ice cream a coffee perhaps no don't
be silly you need to know your fortune
of course yes you must find out if
you're going to come into considerable
wealth or if your partner secretly hates
your guts and desires to leave you
fortune cookies are popular in most
Western countries and foolishly most
Western countries believe they're
actually Chinese whereas in China
they're actually well known for being an
American invention but here's a twist
you're all wrong
it's true that they showed up in the US
well before they were a finger Chinna
but they were actually bought to
California by the Japanese yes Japan
their origin dates back to the 19th
century in Kyoto Japan the Japanese
version of the cookie is called sewage
or assembiy and they are slightly
different from the ones that we know
today
they are a little bit bigger darker in
color and their butter contains sesame
and miso instead of vanilla and butter
the cookies do contain a fortune but the
small piece of paper is wedged into the
bend of the cookie rather than placed
inside it the cookies were modified to
resemble the ones that we know today
after they were brought to America
the original variation of the cookies
are still sold today in some regions of
Japan next up is the supposed in the
Ambala dish chicken tikka masala whilst
you would be forgiven for thinking that
this curry originated in India it is
actually believed to have been
originally invented in the United
Kingdom Glasgow Scotland to be precise
the story goes up in the early 1970s
customer dining at the Indian restaurant
sheesh Mahal in Glasgow campaigned about
the dryness of his chicken dish that he
was served and sent it back to the
kitchen the chef Ali Ahmed Aslam quickly
prepared a sauce which included various
spices and the tin of Campbell's
condensed tomato soup and the famous
dish was born the dish is completely
unheard of in India when you think of
front you probably think of the Eiffel
Tower and berries and just two frozen
more fuel onto the stereotypical fire
sitting outside a cafe smoking drinking
coffee and eating a croissant but it
turns out that this classic French
breakfast pastry isn't actually French I
know rather shocking going back as far
as the thirteenth century an early
ancestor of the croissant can be found
in the form of a traditional Austrian
yeast roll which was made into a
crescent shape called a kick fill
although these types of pastries were
found throughout Europe they were
primarily austria austrian artillery
officer Auguste zhang brought these into
france when he found that his Viennese
bakery in Paris called Belanger avian
walls between 1938 and 1939 Kip Phil's
were a hit with the Parisians so they
nicked it modified it a tiny bit and
their french version of the Austrian
pastry was born they named it across and
after its crescent shape speaking of
things that aren't French french toast
in fact there's evidence to suggest that
the recipe of this eggy fried bread was
around long before France was even a
country in fourth century Rome instead
of discarding their sale bread they were
try to make it more edible by soaking it
in a mixture of egg and milk the origin
is still seen today in what we know as
french toast the French call it pan
perdu which literally means lost bread
but how did it get the name of french
toast whilst this topic is widely
debated a popular myth is that in 1724
an innkeeper named Joseph French in
Albany New York created a dish and
advertise it as French toast he meant to
advertise it as French's toast but the
silly bugger forgot the apostrophe
at the end next up is the Caesar salad
whilst it may be easy to assume that
this came from Rome and was probably
named after Julius Caesar it may
surprise you to learn that this popular
salad was actually invented in Mexico
the salad creator is widely recognized
as restaurateur Caesar Cardini who is an
Italian immigrant that operated
restaurants in Mexico where he created a
dish on an alleged 4th of July in 1924
when he ran out of ingredients and had
to make do with what he had adding a bit
of flair by tableside tossing on the
subject of Mexico for heaters aren't
Mexican LED Texan just across the border
in Texas in the 1940s Mexican ranch
workers living in Texas were given the
least appetizing parts of animals which
were later butchered for food such as
the head intestines and the part which
came to be known as the fajita which was
a thin layer of muscle that covered the
diaphragm the workers tenderize the meat
by pounding it marinating it in lime
juice and cooking it on an open fire
before serving it rolled off in a flour
tortilla the word badger is the Spanish
word for strip the term fajita has
developed over the years for meaning a
cheap piece of meat to describing pieces
of meat wrapped in a tortilla but the
word fajita according to the Oxford
English Dictionary did not appear in
print until 1971 restaurant in
Houston Texas is said to be the biggest
development in what we know today as a
fajita in 1973 an item appeared on the
menu called tacos al Cabana which
consisted of grilled meat strips
condiments and flour tortillas they
later changed the name to fajitas in
1981 next up is the surprising origin of
chips or french fries
they're thought to have been invented in
17th century Belgium although there is
some debate going on about this as
France claims to have invented them
first but they totally didn't the tale
goes up the people of namur are den and
den and in Belgium used to fry the
little fish that they
brought from the Meuse river when the
river froze over during hard winters
they would instead cut potatoes into the
shape of little fish and fry those
instead as to the confusion of why they
called them french fries it is said that
the Belgian national dish les frites was
simply just given the wrong name by
American servicemen at the end of the
first world war when they arrived in
Belgium they named the fried potato
after the French language spoken in
Wallonia the predominantly
french-speaking region of Belgium
therefore translating les Fritz into
french fries if you think that spaghetti
and meatballs as a traditional Italian
dish you'd be wrong in fact if you
travel to Italy it will be very hard to
actually find spaghetti and meatballs on
the menu and if you do happen to find it
it's probably only being served to
satisfy the tourists it turns out that
spaghetti and meatballs as we know them
today was actually invented in the USA
by Italian immigrants between 1880 to
1920 around 4 million Italians
immigrated to America and when from
spending 75 percent of their income on
food to just 25 percent whereas before
they had to make do of the ingredients
that they could find under Ford they
were now able to put meat on the table
quite easily such as meatballs with
canned tomatoes being an easily
accessible source of food at most local
stores the Italian marinara sauce of
wise known as sailor source governed
italian-american food combining these
ingredients together with one of the
only Italian ingredients available
spaghetti the dish of spaghetti and
meatballs was born and made its way on
to dinner tables all over the world
it was consequently given the false
image of an authentic Italian meal last
but certainly not least is the famous
flavoured icy treat that is ice cream
this sumptuous dessert that we know and
love today is said to have been created
in 17th century Italy but the reality is
that ice cream in some shape or form
actually dates back as far as 3000 BC in
China the ice cream back then however
was a far cry from the prepackaged
cornettos and magnums that we enjoy
today the Chinese would use a mixture of
milk and rice to make their ice cream
but in 3,000 BC I'm fairly certain that
they didn't have freezers so how did
they make their ice cream ice cold they
accomplished this by pouring a mixture
of snow and saltpeter around containers
filled with their ingredients just how
salt raises the boiling temperature of
water it also lowers the freezing point
to below zero and there you have it ice
cream fast forward to 1533 and Italian
Duchess Catherine de Medici is credited
for bringing ice cream to Europe she is
said to have brought to France with her
some Italian chefs who had knowledge and
recipes for flavoured sorbets and ices a
hundred years later a legend tells a
tale of how Charles the first of England
was so taken with the frozen snow that
he gave his personal ice-cream maker a
lifetime pension in return for keeping
the formula a secret so that ice cream
could be a royal prerogative thanks for
the view subscribe for more thoughty2
you